[Music]
on this wednesday night making inroads
against russian forces
ukraine reclaims some villages and
residents return
plus the canadian caring for the wounded
in the war zone some of them versus
crying and asking why am i alive rising
worries about rising waters the canadian
communities flooded and the potential
solutions to preserve and protect them
breaking barriers to birth control
pushing for universal access to
contraception in canada
and hitting all the right notes
the ukrainian band crescendoing to a
eurovision victory
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
exact figures about troops killed in
battle have rarely been released by
ukrainian officials tonight that
country's national guard gave a grim
update more than 560 of its soldiers it
says have been killed since the russian
invasion began the battles have been
relentless ukrainian forces have
regained some ground after a counter
offensive north of harkev pushing
russian forces closer towards the border
and fierce battles are underway across
the donbass region russia holds huge
swaths of ukrainian territory along the
black sea
and a kremlin appointed leader is
reportedly pushing for moscow to declare
one of those areas part of russia
redmond shannon begins our coverage
tonight
my beloved land this woman cries
returning home for the first time since
the russian invasion ukrainian troops
say they recaptured villages in harkee
region in recent days
we never expected such aggression from
our neighbors she says in russian where
am i going to live now
this small apparent win for ukraine
stacked up against stalemates and losses
across the east and south
in russian occupied her son a report
that the kremlin-appointed leadership
there now wants the area to formally
join russia similar moves have
previously played out in the two
self-declared republics in the donbass
and fighting continues around snake
island in the black sea scene of the now
famous standoff at the start of the
invasion
meanwhile the bombardment continues at
the azov style steel works in mariupol
photos released by ukraine's as of
battalion claim to show some of the
injured soldiers holed up inside
while at the vatican the wives of two of
those men plead with pope francis for
help
british prime minister boris johnson
visited sweden and finland wednesday in
advance of their expected decisions to
join nato a pledge from the uk to
provide military support
should either nordic nation face an
invasion
in times of crisis cooperation becomes
even more important and this applies not
least for our international defense
partnerships this cooperation it
increases enormously
finnish security elsewhere in europe
russian natural gas flow fell by a
quarter wednesday ukrainian officials
say they've turned off one of the main
transit pipelines going through
ukrainian territory because they claim
occupying russian forces were trying to
steal the gas
donna all right redmond shannon in
london thank you as the war rages on a
canadian doctor has gone to ukraine to
help elena bulactino was born in russia
but left over a decade ago to work as a
forensic pathologist in hamilton ontario
she has volunteered to treat ukraine's
wounded and says nothing prepared her
for what she's seen i haven't seen so
much human tragedy before and these are
like absolutely unnecessary uh
sufferings i understand there's a war
and everybody says well you know there
will be casualties but
when like you know russian sniper just
kills a mother who are going to cross
the bridge like to to european well
there's there's no justification for
that
she says the small hospital where she's
volunteering is mainly working to
stabilize the injured who are then
transferred to bigger hospitals in
western ukraine one of the cities taking
in the wounded and those displaced by
the war is nipra west of the donbass
it's considered a safe haven right now
though it too has been targeted by
russian missiles our crystal gomezing is
there talking to the wounded and those
who are helping them
[Music]
safe and stitched up oleg holds the wad
of metal that nearly ended his life
my soldier and i were in the car the suv
came under fire and exploded behind the
car the glass flew out and wreckage flew
into the cabin the metal embedded in his
skin was so hot it burnt the hands of
the soldier putting pressure on the
wound trying to stop the bleeding for
security reasons global news is not
revealing the full names of the wounded
soldiers here nor any identifying
details about this facility
fifty-two-year-old if hen was also hit
with shrapnel that tore through his
vehicle
a fragment hit me in the side pierced to
the bone
but it's not a problem we will get
through it the men openly detailed their
injuries the stages of care from point
of injury through to reaching a hospital
but both remain concerned for their
comrades in combat
olek a father of two gets emotional when
i ask about his recovery after a moment
he explains that he feels helpless in
the hospital bed
i'm sorry i didn't expect such a
reaction from myself because the guys
from my unit younger men and not as
experienced as me my thoughts are always
with them it's a common sentiment says
this field medic crew the soldiers
they're assigned to treat and transport
to hospital are often unwilling to
accept the gravity of their injuries
there's many shrapnel injured many
shotgun wounds but many concussion
a few weeks after the full invasion of
ukraine by russia oleg balotsky left his
motorcycle racing career to drive an
ambulance
global news was invited to a staging
area where these volunteers were gearing
up for another rotation near the front
lines
i'm not feeling like superman every time
i scare it i every time i have
pens
every
every rotation it's an honest answer
about a terrifying war that heavily
relies on donations
including these ambulances
back at the hospital the chief sergeant
says he found solace in a visit from
some of his company
they are alive and healthy and that is
important to me
both men say as soon as they can they'll
put their uniforms back on
and return to the fight
crystal gamson global news neapro
ukraine
people in parts of southern and central
manitoba are bracing for more rain that
could make the flooding worse and more
people than ever have been displaced by
flooding in communities in the northwest
territories as climate scientists have
warned flooding that used to be rare is
now more frequent and extreme the
question is not if it's going to
continue but how are we going to adapt
eric sorenson reports
it's not just the worst flooding the
pegus first nation has seen it's the
fact that the fisher river now spills
its banks every few years five times in
the last 16 years our planning as far as
the critical infrastructure we're back
filling roads making sure accessibility
chief glenn hudson says they're
sandbagging and getting people to safety
but the traditional response in this
country to evacuate and rebuild does not
recognize that climate change will bring
more flooding to deal with we are very
clearly seeing the increase in the
inundation as well as the water that are
all across the country right now the
pegus first nation is confronting
devastating flood waters but roads are
also flooded in northwestern ontario
with evacuations along james bay
rising waters are forcing people from
their homes in hay river northwest
territories and in bc heavy snow melt
could lead to floods in several regions
notably from north thompson to the upper
fraser and in the most northern parts of
british columbia in bc this spring there
is a lot of snow yet to melt in the
mountains and the latest forecast
suggests major floods could come in june
the risk is that because of the delayed
snow melts all of the elevations of snow
the low the mid and high all melt
simultaneously and and we end up seeing
rapid peaks and rises in the rivers
canada is a nation of rivers and lakes
and there will be more water where
people live in the future for pegus
first nation western university modeling
suggests current conditions along the
fisher river will look like this 100
years from now because of climate change
more area is going to be kind of covered
by
the flats in the future the cost of
rebuilding at the same location is going
to be very high in manitoba some
communities are protected by a ring dike
but for the small spread out people of
peguis first nation there is only
immediate relief what it wants is
infrastructure and a permanent solution
that's their home that's their
livelihood and a place they built of
solace so you know they want to protect
that pegus is not alone over time more
and more canadians will face flooding
and governments will have to do more
than just keep rebuilding eric sorensen
global news toronto
in the u.s a vote for a law to preserve
access to abortion has failed in the
senate and as the u.s supreme court
appears poised to overturn the landmark
1973 roe versus wade ruling that leaves
women and doctors in a precarious
situation jackson proskow explains
the abortion fight traveled from the u.s
supreme court to the senate where
democrats pushed a vote on national
protections for reproductive rights
knowing it was doomed to fail stand with
women to protect their freedoms or stand
with maga republicans and take our
country into a dark
and repressive
future a leaked draft decision from the
supreme court suggests the abortion
access offered by the 1973 roe versus
wade decision is on the cusp of repeal
republicans have hinted they could
institute a national ban if they take
power in congress and the white house in
2024 we stand strongly with the rule of
law we pray for the justices to have
resolve
and we pray for the future of life in
this country
[Applause]
the near certainty of roe's rollback has
fueled protests outside the homes of
supreme court justices
and warnings about the devastating
impact on american society
access to reproductive health care
including abortion
helped lead to increased labor force
participation
it enabled
many women to finish school the biggest
worries are in states like tennessee one
of 13 states with so-called trigger laws
that will automatically ban abortion
once roe is overturned the government is
coming into the exam room and deciding
women's reproductive health for
themselves physicians warn a post-role
world will leave women in jeopardy and
create an ethical quagmire for doctors
who've taken an oath to first do no harm
what happens when that comes up against
the law so our law doesn't really
explicitly state what
you know life of the mother means women
in america are unlikely to get any more
certainty until the court makes its
final ruling later this summer what
happens after that will be decided by
lawmakers and could lead to a system
with vastly different access to abortion
in different parts of the united states
donna
all right jackson thanks the federal
government here in canada has been
criticized for being slow to act after
promising to protect a woman's right to
choose today canada's health minister
announced 3.5 million dollars for two
organizations to help expand access to
abortion that's just a small portion of
a 45 million dollar promise in last
year's budget advocates say there's lots
of other ways to spend the money
including on universal access to all
forms of contraception abigail beeman
looks at what that really means
in my class and just in my friend groups
we have a lot of individuals who cannot
necessarily
use oral contraceptive methods
a really easy and common reason for this
is that
if you have migraines they can actually
make migraines worse medical student
danielle judd is lobbying federal and
provincial politicians for free access
to contraception of all kinds from what
we have heard so far we haven't
had anyone promise to provide
necessarily universal
access to contraception at first glance
that sounds confusing since the new
democrats have been pushing for what
they call exactly that but it's a
complicated topic the canadian
federation of medical students goes
beyond the pill to call for coverage of
all kinds of birth control including
copper iuds right now it's nearly
impossible to get those covered by
insurance iuds fall into a category
known as longer acting contraception if
we switch people from methods like pills
that can fail on average nine percent
per year to a method that fails only
about two and a thousand or point two
percent per year you're actually
significantly reducing the number of
unplanned pregnancies and with that you
significantly reduce uh the health care
costs when we ask the new democrat
leader whether iuds are part of his plan
he was non-committal we want a broadest
possible formulary meaning the list of
medications covered is as broad as
possible setting iuds aside and looking
at the big picture there are all kinds
of barriers to birth control especially
for people who are marginalized low
income or uninsured when we look at the
kind of contraception that is used in
canada
it it appears bound to financial ability
instead of of really what works for
people the liberals say they're open to
the idea but won't get into specifics
it's an important thing to note it is
something that we're looking at
and that's what i'll say for now of
course health care is a provincial
responsibility and coverage vary some
people are eligible for some forms of
birth control coverage in bc ontario and
quebec as examples the canadian
federation of medical students wants the
federal government to make it a
universal mandate canada-wide abigail
beeman global news ottawa
acknowledging its shameful history
coming up the first report on american
residential schools for indigenous
children
for the first time the united states is
examining its history of indigenous
residential schools what were known as
indian boarding schools a new report
found at least 500 native american
alaskan native and native hawaiian
children died while attending indian
boarding schools run or supported by the
u.s government that number falls well
short of some independent estimates of
deaths and does not address how the
children died or who was responsible the
long-awaited study by the u.s interior
department was prompted by the discovery
of unmarked graves at former residential
schools in canada american investigators
found marked and unmarked graves at 53
boarding schools a figure that's
expected to grow and it identified more
than 400 schools across the u.s where
indigenous children were taken the
report also sheds little new light on
the physical and sexual abuse
generations of indigenous children
endured at the schools which were open
for more than 150 years starting in the
early 1800s a veteran journalist with al
jazeera has been shot and killed while
covering an israeli raid in the occupied
west bank and there are calls for an
independent investigation
mourners confronted police outside the
family home of correspondent shireen abu
akla she was shot in the head while with
a group of journalists covering an
israeli army raid on a refugee camp she
was wearing a bulletproof vest with the
words press spelled out on it al jazeera
accuses israel saying she was
assassinated in cold blood by israeli
soldiers israel claims she may have been
hit by palestinian gunfire she was an
american citizen and the white house
press secretary today described her as a
reporting legend and called for an
immediate and thorough investigation and
full accountability
ahead the clash of the conservative
candidates in their first official
leadership debate
the six people in the running for the
leadership of the federal conservative
party are in edmonton tonight for the
first official debate organized by the
party our david aiken is there david the
loudest voices tend to get the most
attention what are you expecting tonight
well donna most of the sound and fury at
last week's debate in ottawa came from
ontario mp pierre pauliev who
aggressively attacked former quebec
premier jean-cheray but tonight we
expect pauliev to turn his guns on the
candidate who is not at last week's
debate in ottawa and that would be
brampton mayor patrick brown looking
forward to a conversation about the
future of the party and the direction we
need to go brown is a former mp and
former ontario pc leader and he will be
getting his first serious challenge of
this leadership race many partisan
observers hope the challenge comes on
policy i think a lot of people are
calling for some civility in this debate
uh you know the conservative coalition
does need to get along i'm running for
prime minister but insiders say paulieb
is not going to change his spots
overnight and he is expected to come at
brown with the same ferocity he came at
charade last week
the average trucker has more integrity
in his pinky finger than you had in your
entire scandal plague liberal cabinet as
joshua arrived for debate rehearsals he
said he'll be happy to have brown join
the group on stage it can only be better
and good because
in the sense that we need you know
everyone on the stage every voice should
be heard
candidate and ontario mpp roman babber
arrived for rehearsal with a just
announced policy proposal he would end
equalization and turn the resulting
savings about 21 billion dollars back to
canadians in the form of tax cuts
meanwhile it cannot be coincidence that
the governing liberals made some
announcements today about two hot button
issues that have tripped up
conservatives in the last two elections
the liberals announced improved abortion
access and tightened gun control we'll
see what conservative leadership
candidates do with that when they kick
things off later tonight donna all right
david aiken in edmonton tonight thanks
rap turned rallying cry next ukrainian
resolve at the world's biggest pop music
contest
the eurovision song contest always has
some surprises this year of course it's
happening against a backdrop of war on
the edge of europe and one of the
front-runners is from ukraine
orchestra mixes rap with ukrainian folk
music and they've been voted through to
the grand final their song has become an
anthem for all the pain their country is
going through heather eurix west reports
[Applause]
the song is called stephania written by
the lead singer of kalush orchestra
before the russian invasion of ukraine
about his mother but now being heard on
the world stage thanks to the eurovision
song contest it has taken on new meaning
the mixture of rap and ukrainian folk
and also you know the i think the
synonyms definitely in the motherland
it's become a synonym for you know
ukraine as a country and you know
fighting for their motherland oh you
know i i watched yesterday and it's like
i cried
for slava sles a ukrainian living in
calgary watching her country advance to
the eurovision final has been a moment
of much needed joy i'm proud of my
country and i'm proud of them from
ukraine for ukrainians it's very
important to feel something good
something
good news there is no escape from the
war even on a platform usually full of
the fantastical and ridiculous russia's
invasion is a constant presence the men
of kaloush orchestra needed special
permission to leave ukraine to compete
at eurovision other men over 18 are
required to stay and fight
and the ukrainian broadcasts of every
performance come from a bomb shelter
in action
we are here to show that ukrainian
culture and ukrainian music exist they
are alive the band says they'll compete
in the final on saturday night we really
hope we were winning
[Laughter]
we think about this will happen
and next year we will celebrate the
eurovision in ukraine
heather urex west global news
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is university bridge in
saskatoon over the south saskatchewan
river thanks for watching hope to see
you here again take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you